Florida Republican gubernatorial
candidate Ron de santis runs up against
a media eager to charge him with racism
the Democratic socialists are on the
March and Cynthia Nixon goes mano-a-mano
with Andrew Cuomo I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show I just want to
clarify something
the phrase mono e mono doesn't actually
mean man versus man
it means hand to hand okay so that
wasn't a sexist comment that they went
mano-a-mano that's actually what it
means so if you idiots start saying that
was a sexist comment it's just cuz
you're stupid
and you don't know anything about
foreign languages there's a lot to talk
about today but before we do any of that
let's talk about your credit card debt
the fact that you're racking up those
credit card charges but you still need
to spend money well the reality is you
don't need to be racking up these big
credit card charges that have the giant
interest rates on the back end instead
you need to go visit my friends over at
lending club with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you
and if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into the bank
account in as little as a few days it's
the number one peer-to-peer lending
platform with over 35 billion dollars in
loans issued so go to Lending Club comm
slash Bend right now you can check your
rate in minutes you borrow up to 40
grand I've looked at the process very
easy go to Lending Club comm slash Bend
that's Lending Club comm slash ban all
loans made by webb bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender again no reason for
you to be racking up these massive
interest charges on a credit card when
you could go to Lending Club and
consolidate all that debt helps you pay
down that debt as well go to Lending
Club comm slash been Lending Club comm
slash been to check your rate in just
minutes alright so I do want to talk
about Ron DeSantis and this insane media
spin that he is a evil vicious races but
I have to begin today with the Pope who
tweeted something crazy out this morning
I don't know what Pope Francis thinks he
is doing I don't know what he thinks his
job is and listen I'm not a Catholic
so there are legitimately a billion
people who know more about Catholicism
than I do on planet earth maybe more
than a billion people who know more
about Catholicism than I do but the
basic information as it has been
conveyed to me is that the Pope is
supposed to be communicating God's Word
on earth and he is the Vicar of Christ
is this correct I think this is the
general idea well this does not sound so
Bikash
shall we say here's what he tweeted out
today we Christians are not selling a
product we are communicating a lifestyle
I didn't realize he was actually guest
starring on Mad Men this week but when
Pope Francis says things like we
Christians are not selling a product
about communicating lifestyle he might
want to think a little bit about the
lifestyle that he and the church have
been communicating in the last few weeks
you know the lifestyle that says that a
Catholic Cardinal Cardinal Theodore
McCarrick can basically run around
shtupping seminarians and he's not gonna
do anything about it that Cardinal
McCarrick can molest children and
apparently that means that he should be
put back in a position of public
importance and that when other Cardinals
approached the Pope the Pope basically
chastises them for there's an awful
awful story that was out today about how
the Pope basically dealt with the
McCarrick situation and apparently he
made some sort of joke about McCarrick
being in the in the clutches of the
devil this is this is an article from
from LifeSite news back in July
apparently McCormack gave a speech let's
see so the story is that Ted mckarrick
was speaking in he was speaking in
October 2003 McCarrick shared a
conversation you had with the newly
elected Pope Francis McCarran told the
audience he had a very serious cardiac
incident well who's the Vatican's during
the 2013 Conclave when you return from
the hospital to the seminary where he
was staying
his phone rang and was the newly elected
Pope Francis online inquiring about
mechanics health mckarrick were laid
this conversation with the Pope quote I
told the Pope that I guess the Lord
still has some work for me to do the
Pope responded to mckarrick but on the
other hand maybe the devil did not have
your accommodations ready and this was
retold in a Washington Post story well
if it turns out that the Pope was aware
of the allegations against mckarrick and
he was making jokes about the devil
having his accommodation ready in 2013
that's not good that's pretty bad and
the Pope has stayed silent on all of
this as I mentioned yesterday the
media's treatment of this issue has been
absolutely incredible just astonishing
because the media was all over the
Catholic sex abuse scandals of the
mid-2000s when we had the the Boston
archdiocese which was caught basically
covering up an enormous number of sex
crimes and the media rightly was after
the the Catholic Church for that in a
way they about that by who had never
been over secular institutions that
engage in sex abuse when it's a second
one institution engaging in
that's just par for the course when it's
the Catholic Church then it's a huge
ordeal according to the media it should
be a huge deal in either case but at
least the media was going after the
right folks back in 2006 now of course
the media is interested in protecting
Pope Francis because they feel that he
reflects their political priorities if
you want to know what's best for the
Catholic Church never trust the New York
Times the New York Times is a pretty
good indicator of exactly what the
Catholic Church should not be doing
because you know what the New York Times
editorial board would love more than
anything else for all Catholics to stop
being Catholic they would like to see
the Catholic Church utterly destroyed
just as they would like to see
Protestant churches destroyed just as
like the Justice they would like to see
Orthodox Judaism destroyed the secular
media has an extraordinary bias against
religious institutions that they see as
being restrictive and repressive of
individual freedoms particularly on
issues of sexuality so if they're
upholding a particular Pope it's a fair
bet that that Pope is not a friend to
traditional Catholic doctrine and it's
certainly fair to say that the Pope's
activities over the last several months
here are creating a serious possibility
of a schism within the Catholic Church I
mean there's a serious possibility here
they you could actually see a break in
the Catholic series break in the
Catholic Church for the first time in
half a millennium then that's not really
an exaggeration I'm hearing from a lot
of Catholic friends I'm not even talking
about people who are politically
conservative I have a lot of Catholic
friends who are saying that this is
making them seriously doubt the ability
of this Pope to continue in his current
job there's no impeachment procedure for
Pope's he's there until he decides to
step down so it's it's a real problem
and the fact that the Pope is tweeting
out these nonsensical nostrums from
Cosmo magazine just demonstrates that he
never was fit for the job I mean listen
there are those of us who have been very
critical of Pope Francis since day one
because it's very clear that Pope
Francis had a certain political spin a
Marxist spin on his own version of
Catholic doctrine and as somebody who
doesn't have a dog in the fight other
than I think the Catholic Church is a
deeply important institution to the
foundations of Western civilization and
I think the Catholic Church's continued
health is absolutely vital to the
continuation of central values that
perpetuate the power and glory of
Western civilization that's my stake in
this but I don't have a stake in this as
a practicing Catholic because I'm not
Christian that said when I see the
Catholic Church being brought low by its
own leadership on the basis of political
leftism because whether Pope Francis
thinks that he has to appeal to a
different crowd and
to raise the raise the rates of
conversion in poorer parts of the world
or whether he's just pandering to a
leftist press or whether he actually
believes this stuff what he is doing
it's so obviously undermining the
foundations of the Catholic Church that
is pretty astonishing again the New York
Times very Pro Francis because Francis
was every five minutes they run a
headline about Francis talking about
homosexuality because he's much more to
the left on homosexuality even while
still supposedly abiding by Catholic
doctrine they don't know never on
headlines about Pope Francis not
abortion of course where he is
traditionally well within the the sort
of Catholic doctrine it shows you where
the press is in all this and it shows
you why there's so many Catholics who
are really uncomfortable today about the
leadership of the Catholic Church it's a
serious problem
okay so meanwhile in the United States
we are fighting over much less serious
issues because the future of the
Catholic Church is a lot more important
than any one election that's happening
in the United States but demonstrating
more of the presses just utter
incapacity to tell the truth
yesterday the press went absolutely
insane over a comment by Ron de santis
now full disclosure I know congressman
DeSantis he's a representative in the
House of Representatives he is the new
Florida Republican gubernatorial
candidate he's a down the line
conservative I'm friendly with
congressman DeSantis but even where I
not this is just a bunch of crap
basically Rhonda Sanchez was was on Fox
News and he was talking about his
opponent a guy named Gilliam Andrew
Gilliam who's the mayor of Tallahassee
who also happens to be embroiled in an
FBI investigation of the Tallahassee
mayor's office but more importantly
Andrew Gilliam is a very very left
Kennedy's 39 years old he's basically a
Democratic Socialist like Alexandra
Ocasio Cortes we'll talk in a little bit
about what his victory in Florida means
and how it happened but Ron DeSantis was
talking about his opponents in this race
because basically a dead even race and
here's what Ron DeSantis had to say but
I mean he performed better than the
other people there so so we've got to
work hard to make sure that we continue
Florida going in a good direction let's
build off the success we've had on
governor Scott the last thing we need to
do is to monkey this up by trying to
embrace a socialist agenda with huge tax
increases and bankrupting the state that
is not going to work that's not gonna be
good for Florida okay so what's amazing
about this did you hear anything in
there that sounded really racist did you
hear anything in there that sounded
deeply racist to you
apparently that was deeply racist
apparently it was incredibly racist why
because he used the phrase monkey this
up now monkey is as used as a verb is
used routinely routinely by all sorts of
people here for example is a clip of
Barack Obama using the term monkeying
around was Obama being racist no because
when you say monkey something up or
monkey around you are clearly using it
as a verb meaning like a monkey wrench
like you're tinkering with things it's
legitimately in dictionary calm is legit
the only definition of monkey as a verb
is to mess around with that's literally
the only definition but we are supposed
to believe that Ron DeSantis used the
term monkey this up as some sort of dog
whistle to a bunch of racists in the
sticks who weren't aware that Andrew
Gilliam is a gay black man it's an
amazing thing anyway here is here is
Barack Obama using it in 2008
it's not as if it's just Republicans who
have monkeyed around with elections in
the past sometimes Democrats have to you
know whenever people are in power
they're you know they have this tendency
to try to you know tilt things in their
direction so monkeying around is not an
overtly racist phrase not a racist
phrase hey there's nothing about that
phrase that is racist but it is racist
because you cannot use monkey and
apparently socialist in the same
sentence so even in that sentence he
wasn't talking about Andrew Gilliam
being black right which actually would
probably be racist if you use monkey and
then you say like and I don't want them
monkeying it up by electing a black
candidate that sounds racist right that
sounds like you were making it overtly
racist comments about the guy you're
running against he said we don't want a
monkey up the economy by electing a
socialist to lead our state that is not
a racist thing and honestly I'm puzzled
by the theory I'm very puzzled by the
theory so apparently the theory is that
Ron de santis was desperately trying to
reach out to the Trump voters he already
has in his pocket remember Ron de santis
ran the most Pro Trump campaign in
America he ran an actual ad in which he
dressed his kid his baby in a trump
onesie and the according to the media
ultram voters are racist which means all
the racists were already voting for
Rhonda Sanchez but apparently it was
deeply necessary that he had to we had
to somehow dog-whistle to these five
people who were gonna vote against
Andrew Gilliam because he's black by
using the phrase let me just remind you
monkey it up
I gotta that that was his actual idea
that so that's what he was going for
according to the media
amazingamazing accusation again so he
was using monkey as a verb in a commonly
used phrase in order to make an oblique
reference to a noun in order to appeal
to people who are already voting for him
thinking the media wouldn't catch on and
therefore driving an entire news cycle
against him I mean this the mashin
nations that DeSantis had to go through
apparently in order to come up with this
racist dog whistle the genius of it
the sheer genius of it should boggle the
mind but of course all this is a bunch
of crap I'm gonna talk in a second about
the backlash on all this it's so
dishonest but first let's talk about
something a little bit more enjoyable
there's a new podcast out there that has
an amazing story to tell you're really
gonna like it it's called inside jaws
it's written and hosted by Mark Ramsey
the man behind inside psycho and inside
the Exorcist it is a look at the 1975
pulse-pounding hit film jaws the first
ever summer blockbuster and how it was
made I love the movie Jaws if you
haven't seen it you're really missing
out it really holds up it's a terrific
terrific film Robert chuck is an
all-time great performance and this
podcast is all about exactly how that
movie got made you'll follow Steven
Spielberg from making of his first
8-millimeter Western his young Boy Scout
to the rocky production and
groundbreaking breaking release of a
movie to change the film industry
forever I mean folks legitimately
thought that Charles gonna bankrupt the
studio because it was so expensive and
instead it ended up being one of the
biggest hits of all time listen today by
subscribing to inside drawers on Apple
podcast or heading over to wonder EFM
slash inside jaws or you can listen to
the first four episodes ad free by
signing up for one during plus at wonder
EECOM slash plus
that's wo n de ry com slash plus-1 dree
FM slash inside jaws or wonde recom
slash plus go subscribe to inside
drawers today it really is enjoyable
it's really a lot of fun particularly in
the summer months so the media are not
satisfied with simply suggesting that
Rhonda census is an evil Republican he's
a racist for using a term that is
commonly used politically like all the
time in fact Andrew Gilliam himself the
Tallahassee Democrat has has said in the
past that that his opponents were like
monkeys on his back so you it turns out
there are lots of ways to use the word
monkey without actually making a
racially charged reference designed to
elicit a certain response from the evil
racists who supposedly make up your base
but that's not going to stop the
Democrats from jumping on this and fully
dishonest fashion they did the same
thing by the way to Mitt Romney
back in 2006 Mitt Romney
so that the Big Dig in Boston which I
was there for this they were digging a
tunnel and the drill got stuck it cost
them billions of dollars and he
suggested the project was at our baby
meaning that the the project was costing
money and you'd spend the money and then
you'd have to spend more money on it and
people pointed out that the phrase tar
baby has a racist history going back to
like the Brer Rabbit tales of the 19th
century and suddenly it was that MIT
Romney was making some sort of veiled
racist reference about a tunnel project
that's what Mitt Romney was doing I
remember they did the same thing to
George Allen in Virginia there was an
there's an Indian guy who was following
his campaign at the behest of his
senatorial opponent and the Indian guy
following his campaign not like Native
American like India from from India and
George Allen said something like oh you
see this guy following our campaign
around I know his name is like macaca or
something and then it turned out that
macaca was a portuguese slur for black
person and so people said well his use
of the term macaca was directly directed
at the indian guy who's making arrests a
racist reference to a random reporter in
the back of the room in order to gin up
the base in Virginia and it basically
caused George Allen to lose the election
I mean George Allen legitimately lost a
senatorial election on the basis of this
it's why just a couple of days ago here
on this show when we were talking about
a British story about men wearing frilly
underwear and the British word for
underwear is knickers KNI CK ers I had
to spell it out and explain exactly what
word I was using because otherwise Media
Matters would claim that I was using the
n-word right there in 1999 there was a
guy in the mayor's office in Washington
DC who used the word niggardly niggardly
means stingy it has nothing to do with
the n-word the guy was fired for using
that word back in 1999 so this is the
part of the DeSantis thing that's so
incredible is that you the the
assumption here is that he was using the
term monkey this up knowing that the
climate is such that it would completely
destroy his candidacy or at least harm
his candidacy specifically to appeal to
five people who are already gonna vote
for him because they voted for Trump
which according to the media means
they're racists yes I'm sure that the
Yale grad and the Harvard Law grad is
secretly a deep racist who is attempting
to use a southern strategy in a state he
is likely to win already
yeah I'm sure I'm sure that's exactly
what he was going for but that's what
the media decide to push out so here is
Andrew gillum's response he says of
course this isn't just a racist dog
whistle it's a bullhorn
it's a bullhorn which seems you know
discriminatory against male cattle but
who am I to say well in the the handbook
of Donald Trump they no longer do
whistle calls they're now using full
bull horns and that was a boy what I've
got to say about that is that we've got
to make sure that we stay focused I
think on the issues that confront
everyday people that was a bullhorn my
goodness I mean I think it'd be fair to
say that the President of the United
States has used more of this dog
whistling than than Ronda Santos like I
think the Charlottesville thing was
really egregious I did I think several
full episodes on the Charlottesville and
to know what the President of the United
States but to claim that the phrase
monkey this up with reference to
socialism destroying the economy is some
sort of racist dog whistle or racist
bullhorn you want to know how you got
Trump I know we use this phrase too much
but it's it's something that the left
needs to understand the reason that
Trump is president of the United States
is because you cried wolf too many times
you keep saying that every Republican
who ever makes any reference to
something that has nothing to do with
race is actually making a covert racist
reference and using Richard Nixon's 1972
Southern Strategy this is the case
you're making you claims that Mitt
Romney was a racist Mitt Romney you
claimed that John McCain was a racist
John McCain right you claimed all these
people were racist now you're claiming
Ron DeSantis is a racist you cried wolf
so many times over a dog whistle and it
turns out that when there are actual dog
whistles no one pays attention to you
anymore because it basically here's what
you do right Donald Trump says something
that's actually bad you guys and you
guys go well you know that's a dog
whistle and go
you mean like Mitt Romney was a dog
whistle they're like well yeah but but
no it's like well okay so which reline
any lying now which one is it and the
answer of course is that they were lying
that's the real answer but here's an
MSNBC panel slamming Ron DeSantis
Clinton of course Jen Rubin of course
Jen Rubin the in-house conservative at
the Washington Post you can't see me
right now I'm making scare quotes with
my fingers yes Jen Rubin the in-house
conservative so conservative that she's
now to the left of Bill Maher on many
issues here she is on MSNBC explaining
that DeSantis is a vicious racist with
no evidence of course the Santa is a
trumpet he
fans racial hatred he fans fear of
immigrants and then I think it's gonna
come out in the campaign because that's
what these guys do and they can't help
themselves I think that it was clearly
racist I mean look the remark didn't
even make any sense it wasn't a rational
argument or response to the conversation
at hand what he was literally talking
about a socialist messing up the economy
and then you use the phrase monkey this
up as opposed to muck this up or screw
this up
or eff this up right like what but this
is what this how the media's gonna play
this DeSantis is obviously irritated by
this he dismissed the racism charges as
this is this is just ridiculous and of
course he's right it has zero to do with
race Shaun has everything to do with
whether we want Florida to continue to
go in a good direction building off the
success or do we want to turn to
left-wing socialist policies which will
absolutely devastate our state okay the
Washington Post however was not buying
this The Washington Post suggests that
it is absolutely true that this is a
racist statement this is legitimately
written in a newspaper right in a major
newspaper in the United States quote
comparing black people particularly tall
athletically built black men like
Gilliam to monkeys apes or primates is
one of the oldest stereotypes in history
no one did that he didn't even use the
word monkey as a noun like that what and
then and then there is a full four
hundred word explanation of the history
of comparing people the monkeys which is
not what he did right leading American
scientists in the 1850s embrace
scientific racism to conclude that black
people's similarities to Apes was so
significant that it influenced laws
policies and other decisions about
African Americans yes I'm sure that Ron
de santis is a scientific racist from
1852 I'm sure that that's exactly what
he was doing yeah this idea entered
American pop culture of blockbuster
levels and thus became more widespread
via early 20th century films like Tarzan
and King Kong and images depicting black
people as Apes became common in anti
black art during the Jim Crow era of
government-sponsored segregation what in
the hell are you actually accusing to
Santis up are you accusing the Santis of
being an 1850s tile scientific racist
are you accusing him being a Jim Crow
Democrat is that what you are accusing
Ron DeSantis a Florida Republican of is
that the
you're going and now I guess you're
comparing him to Roseanne Barr who
compared Valerie Jarrett to an ape but
this is I guess where where the entire
left media's gonna go I can't imagine
why people think the media lie to them
it just it's it's unthinkable to me how
could people think that the media lied
to them now does that justify the
President of the United States saying
enemy of the people no it doesn't but
doesn't mean that more Americans are
less likely to trust the media you bet
your ass and meanwhile the media won't
cover the actual facts about Andrew
Gilliam so now let's talk about Andrew
Gilliam in just one second because there
are some things you should know about
Andrew Gilliam this beloved Democrat who
they want to prop up to the Florida
governorship on the basis of lies about
race baiting we'll talk about that in
just one second - first let's be clear
it is very tough these days to get
people to agree on anything as you can
tell from the show every day we're in
the political fight every day we're in
the political muck very difficult to get
people to agree on anything but one
thing that we can all agree on is that
we ought to be saving money and the
easiest way to do that is to go register
over at honey honey is a free shopping
tool it automatically searches the
internet for the best promo codes every
time you buy something online they
believe that everyone deserves the best
prices possible on all the stuff they
love which is why it works out over
30,000 sites including Amazon honey has
already saved people 800 million dollars
online 800 million right it's an amazing
amazing service the way that it works is
that you go over to join honey calm /
Ben and you install it on your computer
and then you just go over to Amazon or
wherever it is you shop and you shop and
it finds these promo codes and it
inserts them for you automatically and
that ensures that you are getting the
best possible deal I've used honey over
at Amazon I actually bought my wife an
instant pot at the behest of Bethany
Mandel who writes over for for a variety
of publications Bethany is an instant
pot acolyte
this isn't marijuana it's an actual like
pot that you cook with and I bought my
wife an instant pot using honey and we
got the we got a solid discount on it
honey has 10 million members a hundred
thousand plus five star reviews honey
members save an average of 28.6 teen one
cents a month go get honey for free
right now at join honey calm / Ben that
is join honey calm / Ben again you can
get honey for free right now it's a
money-saving shopping tool that
everybody can agree on go check it out
right now join honey calm / Ben okay so
now let's talk about the real story with
regard to Andrew Gilliam the media
doesn't want to talk about Andrew
Gilliam as a socialist he's a Democratic
Socialist along the lines of Alexandra
Ocasio Cortese which is to say the
he will conveniently praise capitalism
when he must but he will generally say
the capitalism is a bad thing and he
will claim that he's not a socialist
when he sort of is a socialist Lee this
is the new game that we play if we are
Democrats we say we're a Democratic
Socialist which means we don't want to
nationalize all industry or abolish the
profit motive unless we're talking to
our base in which case we kind of want
to nationalize all industry or a Bosch
abolish the profit motive but we have to
do this gradually and we want to start
off like Norway like Norway where we
have capitalistic principles but lots of
social programs stacked on top of those
capitalist principles and if it costs
just a crapload of money then we'll just
do it anyway so Gilliam Andrew Gilliam
is the is the mayor of Tallahassee as I
talked about yesterday on the program
the FBI is investigating the Tallahassee
mayor's office for use of public private
contracts to toss money to some of the
andrew.galea to some of gillum's friends
it is worth noting that Andrew gillum's
rise is paid for by rich people
so Andrew Gilliam is is making hay right
now specifically because they're
billionaires who are backing him it's
also important to know that Andrew
Gilliam won this particular primary
because he's running in a three-way
primary and the votes split so in much
the same way that martha mcsalley
who won a pretty clear-cut victory over
Joe Arpaio and and Kelly Ward in Arizona
she won in part at least because that
vote was split I think a 17% for Arpaio
28% for Kelly Ward and the right person
won in martha mcsalley who's a good
candidate Air Force colonel I believe in
any case the same sort of thing happened
in Florida where Andrew Gilliam won this
race specifically because the vote split
between two other viable candidates in
the floor to raise both of them ignored
Gilliam and he ran directly to the left
and he just ran the inside rail
basically but he was also backed by
literally millions of dollars from
liberal billionaire so Tom Styer dumped
millions and millions of dollars into
this campaign George Soros dumped
millions this is not conspiracy theory
this is reported by The New Yorker
Gilliam had recognized the big money in
the Democratic Party
Thomas tires money George Soros his
money is now on the left not the center
last year Gilliam watched closely as
Soros has cash helped propel progressive
candidates to victory in several local
elections including the Philadelphia
District Attorney's race Gilliam was
familiar with sorrows and his
organization the open society foundation
a few years ago he helped launch a
national network for young progressive
elected officials and the open society
foundation was the group's main donor so
this is a Soros guy he'd been in the
finance
year's New York apartment addressed his
board of directors and the spring dined
with him in San Francisco when the two
men happened to be in town sorrows
committed to baculum screw Burnet Oriole
campaign he says if I'm remembering it
correctly it was we don't know if you
can win but we would like what it could
represent I interpret it to mean that
would be significant to see a person of
color taken seriously in a statewide
race no it actually means the George
Soros PACs a lot of socialists I know
we're gonna turn everything into a color
issue but it has very little Duluth
color and everything to do with gillum's
economic policies which are indeed
extraordinarily left and you wouldn't
muck up the economy you would screw up
the economy if you actually were to
embrace all of his policies even Gilliam
understands by the way that if he runs
too far left he's actually honest about
his own ambitions that he ends up
undercutting the economy so he was asked
specifically about his medicare-for-all
plan so Medicaid for all is what
Medicare for all is what he's pushing
just like Bernie Sanders just like
Alexander Ocasio cortes sure it's gonna
cost a minimum of 32 trillion dollars
tripling the federal budget over the
next ten years sure it's going to
bankrupt virtually everyone in the
country sure that's a minimum that it
will cost cuz it'll actually cost a lot
more than that that thirty two trillion
dollars doesn't take into account
renegotiations doctor pay raises it
doesn't take into account all of the
additional cost that will be necessary
Medicare can exist at its current levels
because a lot of people have private
insurance you do Medicare for all
private insurance disappears and the
costs are gonna be a lot more than
thirty two trillion dollars in any case
even Gilliam understands that his agenda
issue far left so he's basically
soft-pedaling it here he is explaining
that he won't try Medicare for all in
Florida alone because he needs a
confederation of states which is a way
to say I'm for Medicare for all unless I
actually have to bear the political
brunt of Medicare for all if for Florida
move in that direction we would have to
do it as a confederation of states we
could not do it by ourselves so solely
here in the state of Florida because it
would collapse the system we would only
attract the sickest of patients and it
wouldn't work listen people are
terrified of getting sick they're
terrified of getting sick because if
they get sick they can't go to work and
if they can't go to work they can't earn
a wage of basically okay I love the
Chris Cuomo there is actually feeding
him the talking points on CNN well you
know you should say here is what you
should say is you're a paycheck away
from poverty if you get sick and end
rooms like yeah that's right yeah I'm
sure that's exactly how Chris Cuomo
coaches Republicans through interviews
as well CNN
objective news network I love that
Andrew Gilliam there basically explains
the rationale for why Medicare won't
work at any level they says all it will
do is attract all the sick people who
will then over tax the system and
they're gonna have to pay for it somehow
so we'll do it it's not in Florida when
I'm governor so we should do it but we
won't do it because it'll be expensive
and will bankrupt the system but we
should do it right yeah I can't imagine
why folks are looking at this as a
fantasy candidacy but it's very easy to
promise things that will never come to
fruition Gilliam and then says I'm not a
socialist when he's called on all this
stuff he says don't worry I'm not a
socialist I'm just a Democrat I'm just a
Democrat yeah well I mean it shouldn't
surprise you it doesn't surprise me that
the president is again creating fairy
tales on it's really quite a socialist
no I'm a Democrat I ran as a Democrat I
am a Democrat and frankly the values at
a whole I think are consistent with the
values of the Democratic Party in fact I
think they are the values here though by
the majority of Floridians no what I do
love about this the most is that there's
no follow-up question from Chuck Todd at
MSNBC okay so tell me the difference
between a Democrat and socialist
remember they actually asked Nancy
Pelosi that questions you couldn't
answer it what's the difference between
a democratic socialist and a socialist
what's the difference between the
Democratic platform and a Democratic
Socialist platform and the Democrats
won't answer it so this is just fudging
their way out of the fact that their
policies are completely out of left
field but Gilliam is going to run a
strong race now based on a media that
wishes to push him to victory
we'll see how successfully the media can
do all of that
the irony of all this of course is that
because of this push to the left that's
been happening at least in part thanks
to a left-wing media that loves this
kind of stuff other candidates are also
seeing rise one of those candidates
delightfully enough is Cynthia Nixon so
Cynthia Nixon the former Sex in the City
star whose political background consists
entirely of being the least likable
member of a cast that included Sarah
Jessica Parker she is going to actually
she's running against Chris against
Chris's brother Andrew and they've been
running gun battle Andrew and Chris for
stupidest Cuomo brother Chris
occasionally takes the lead but then
Andrews sort of surges and will see that
even on today's show right so what you
see there is that Chris Cuomo actually
made a strong showing he broke out of
the get real fast but we'll see in a
second that Andrew Cuomo really makes a
Secretariat like
poll away at the end here of the show
we'll get to that in just a second but
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daily wire comm and subscribe for $9.99
a month you can get a subscription to
daily wire.com you get the rest of my
show the rest of Andrew Clavin show the
rest of Michael moles a show if that's
something that you're into also you can
be part of our mailbag which we are
doing tomorrow so you sending all your
questions and I answer them for you
and I make your life inestimable better
in every possible respect also if you
want the annual subscription and for $99
a year you can get all of those glories
plus the left is tears hut or cold
tumblr directs from God to you it is
just spectacular in every possible way
the leftist year's hot or cold tumblr
you will enjoy it is also cheaper than
the monthly subscription so go check
that out right now when you do then you
also got our Sunday special if you go to
the YouTube page or our iTunes page and
you subscribe we have Sunday special our
Sunday special this week is with
Professor Edie fazer who is a theologian
and philosopher specifically with regard
to sort of the traditional proofs of
God's existence so it's a very deep
stuff that we did on the Sunday special
we have a bunch of upcoming guests who
are great as well Christina Hoff Sommers
is coming up Andrew Klavan actually he's
going to stop by for an hour so we have
a bunch of great guests we're coming up
go subscribe right now we always
appreciate we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
as I predicted Cynthia Nixon debated
Chris Cuomo not Chris I keep mixing up
Chris and Andrew because yeah who cares
but Andrew Cuomo the governor of New
York was debating Cynthia Nixon and as I
predicted you get Andrew Cuomo in room
with Cynthia Nixon it's not gonna go
well for Andrew Cuomo and the reason
it's not gonna go well for Andrew Cuomo
is cuz he actually has to govern the
state he actually has to be governor of
the state whereas Cynthia Nixon can sit
on the side and talk smack basically she
can sit there and just yell at Andrew
Cuomo for governing the state and all he
can do is complain about how her
performance was sort of lackluster in
the late seasons of Sex in the City
that's basically his only pitch so they
have this debate and it's just amazing
to watch because it legitimately is like
watching two small children club' each
other with frying pans neither of them
have very compelling points to make but
they make them the most militant
possible way as someone with the two and
a half year old son I'm familiar with
how two and a half year olds argue
basically they say I want X and you say
you can't have X and then they lie on
the floor and they scream and kick
that's basically how the scoober
notorious mate went but because one of
them is the sitting governor of a state
he looks small compared to Cynthia Nixon
who looks like the surging the surging
candidate I would not be surprised to
see I'll predict her now I would not be
surprised to see Cynthia Nixon pull out
this race it would not surprise me in
the slightest to see Cynthia Nixon surge
from behind and at least make this a
very competitive race right now she's
about 30 points behind in the polls but
the polls are done infrequently and
Andrew Cuomo is one of the more
lackluster candidates I have ever seen
he makes gaffes on a regular basis and
Cynthia Nixon at least has the sincerity
of her convictions and since we live in
a political age where sincerity is
prized far more than actually knowing
things when you being sincere is really
really important but he truly feels this
she truly believes this that's much more
important then you know what the hell
you're talking about
it appears that Cynthia Nixon I think
she won this debate I think she wanted
going away and it's really really funny
so here is here's Andrew Cuomo trying to
critique Cynthia Nixon last night by
saying that she lives in a fantasy world
and listen to the audience's response is
over at Hofstra University which is
which would be friendly ground for
Andrew Cuomo except he's running against
the gal from Sex in the City
my opponent lives in the world of
fiction I live in the world of
let's do let's just do a few facts okay
this subway system is owned by New York
City okay the reason that he's saying
that is because she said that Andrew
Cuomo is using the MTA as an ATM which
is a clever line it's not exactly true
he's actually right that the MTA is run
by the city of New York and they have
not been contributing their fair share
of the state has been chipping in a lot
of money she's not wrong that he's
directing money away from the MTA and
toward other projects but the fact that
he's getting openly booed in the middle
of debates by people this looks a lot
like Bernie Sanders versus Hillary
Clinton
it looks like the anti-establishment
candidate versus the establishment
candidate and the establishment
candidate still has to pay lip service
to you know the things that actually
make the state run whereas Cynthia Nixon
can sit there and say whatever she wants
also Andrew Cuomo then participates in
one of the great cellphones I have seen
in in recent debate history I mean this
is a cell phone of epic proportions you
just have to you just have to listen
it's really incredible as soon as you do
it be okay that is what we call an
own-goal right there so he asked her to
stop interrupting and she says as soon
as you stop lying he says I will when
you do okay that logically just just
putting on your logic hat for a minute
that means he just admitted that he lies
all the time and then he will stop lying
as soon as she stops lying so you have
two Liars on the stage is what he's
saying what why you're the liar or in
the famous words of President Trump who
the puppet he should have said something
along those lines instead he comes back
with I'll stop lying when you just as I
say in the running gun battle for
stupidest Cuomo brother Chris had an
early lead in this episode but Andrew
makes a very late comeback and this is
the best part so Andrew Cuomo goes after
Cynthia Nixon and he wants to accuse her
of corruption so how in the world could
he accuse her of corruption he suggests
that she had engaged in corporate
lobbying what was her corporate lobbying
she'd asked that the city of New York
and that the city of New York not allow
helicopters to fly over Central Park
during performances of Shakespeare in
the park because it was disturbing
people's ability to watch the play that
was his example of Cynthia Nixon
in corporate Lobby good luck with that
Andrew you are a corporation anyone's
political campaign or a corporation I
donate through my own volition I am a
person but I do not ever make political
contributions but you might yes true
okay so that it's so funny to watch them
go at this because again it's two small
children clubbing each other or frying
pans what he's saying is that you're
legally organized as a corporation for
purposes of taxes just like half of rich
people in the United States more than
half virtually everybody who has any
money in the United States has an Inc or
an LLC or an S corp right yes everyone
does everyone does because you do this
for tax purposes because then you write
off all your expenses into the
corporation then the corporation files
taxes and signs you a check at the end
of the day I know I'm organized exactly
the same way anybody who as soon as you
learn a certain level of money it
becomes beneficial tax wise to do this
so it's true that Cynthia Nixon is a
corporation the great irony of this
particular debate is that both of them
believe that corporations should be less
involved in politics but he's
acknowledging and so is she a basic
truth people are corporations very says
you're a corporation she goes I'm not a
corporation I'm a person he says right
but you organizes a corporation and she
says right but I'm a person right both
of you are arguing that people shouldn't
be able to speak politically so long as
they're organized as corporations which
makes no sense at all but again this is
what you get when sincerity and
socialists kind of talking points come
to the fore I do love that the same
people proclaiming money in politics are
bad are going and hitting up George
Soros and Tom Steyer for millions of
dollars in campaigns and the two people
who are running for governor in New York
are a very very wealthy actress who
calls herself a socialist and Andrew
Cuomo the son of a former governor of
New York and the brother of a CNN host
who obviously yeah this is a guy who
clearly brought himself up by the
bootstraps I mean this is a guy who had
to work his way from the bottom of
American society really grasping that
bottom rung just pulling himself up step
by step okay meanwhile it's it's worthy
talking about the President of the
United States who's now on a tear
against Bruce or I'd be remiss if I
didn't
mentioned this because this has become a
major issue the President of the United
States is ripping into Bruce or who's
the former Deputy Assistant Attorney
General of the over at the Department of
Justice he was deeply involved in a
variety of issues he spent more than 25
years at the Justice Department and he's
drawn president Trump's ire so President
Trump was was going after Bruce or
suggesting that Bruce or his security
clearance should be revoked that he's
been involved in an attempt to basically
stop President Trump from from being
successful Trump tweeted in the last
couple of weeks quote Bruce of the
Justice Department can you believe he's
still there he's accused of helping
disgraced Christopher steel find hurt on
Trump or its wife Nelly was in on the
act big-time worked for fusion GPS on
fake dossier and then he continued the
big story that the fake news media
refuses to report is a low-life
christopher's steals many meetings with
deputy AG bruiser and his beautiful wife
Nelly well very has they had the
adjective it was fusion GPS that hired
Steele to write be phony and discredited
dossier paid for by crooked Hillary and
the DNC I felt like now's a good time to
actually explain what's going on here
cuz you're seeing a lot of attention to
Bruce or in the conservative media so
let's explain what exactly happened here
so Bruce or it's a longtime DOJ official
he was friends with Christopher Steele
and it looks like he was communicating
with Christopher Steele even after
Christopher Steele the author of the
fusion GPS dossier against President
Trump was basically cut off by the FBI
so the FBI said we can't talk to
Christopher steel anymore because he was
leaking to the media and then it turns
out Broussard was still talking with
Christopher Steele and apparently taking
that information and passing it on to
the FBI so despite the FBI deciding they
would no longer work with Steele Bruce
or was trying to act it looks like as an
intermediary for Steele's information to
get to the FBI now all of this is in the
aftermath of the election there are two
accusations that are being made one of
them has some evidentiary support one of
them has not a lot of evidentiary
support the prints that the one that has
some evidentiary support is the idea
that Bruce or whose wife Nellie does
work for fusion GPS there's a whole
nexus here Nellie works for fusion GPS
and Bruce works for the DOJ and Bruce's
friends with Christopher Steele Nellie
hired Bruce Nellie hired Christopher
Steele to at least in part come up with
this fusion GPS dossier he then met with
Bruce or was funneling him information
or was funneling that to the FBI the the
accusation one is being made that all of
this information is what led to the
continuation of the Muller investigation
and to the wiretap on on Carter page
that all of this led to the FISA
application against Carter page that the
effusion GPS dossier was used as the
basis for the FISA application against
Carter page and that it never should
have been and was being basically
treated corruptly by Bruce or because he
wanted to get President Trump there is
some evidence of that although I will
again note that the actual FISA
application has a full footnote at the
bottom of the application that
specifically talks to the court about
how this was an Apple research piece of
dossier that was handed by Hillary
Clinton's campaign to the DOJ and the
FBI so it's not entirely true that the
court had no idea that this was a piece
of Apple research and to take it with a
grain of salt what it really does raises
the question of how easily the FISA
Court actually gives out warrants for
for wiretapping people I think it more
goes to a systemic problem that's
accusation number one accusation number
two is the one that I haven't seen the
dots fully connected on and I try to be
as objective as I can in my assessment
of which dots have been connected so far
the dots that are trying to be connected
is what a lot of fans are trying to do
is basically get to the point where they
can claim that the entire Mullen
investigation and the rush occlusion
investigation is fruit of the poisonous
tree meaning that it was initiated in
bad faith by opponents of President
Trump specifically in order to stop from
from being president and therefore the
Muller investigation now is fruit of
that poisonous tree it is poisonous as
well and Trump would be well within his
rights to fire Robert Muller and
therefore stop the investigation that's
the case they're trying to make now the
problem with that case is that the
original investigation according to
Devin Nunes right who is the
representative leading this particular
investigation into the investigation
right Devin hoon is the head of the
House Intelligence Committee he says
that the George papadopolis
investigation the investigation of a
low-level foreign policy aide who worked
for Trump and was communicating with
what appeared to be a Russian cutout
that's what led to the investigation so
it had nothing to do with Bruce or it
had nothing to do with Christopher
Steele the accusation that's being made
is that Bruce or and Christopher Steele
that's the real reason that the Muller
investigation was launched the evidence
isn't there for that yet the best
evidence they have is that Christopher
Steele in Bruce or met on July 30th 2016
in the middle of the campaign and the
next day the investigation launched but
it's not clear that's what launched the
investigation usually it takes a couple
of months to actually initiate that
process so we'll have to see if that
final bout is connected if that final
that is connected then you have the
serious possibility that the entire
thing was trumped up there's a
difference by the way between the
investigation not coming up with
anything and the investigation
originally being trumped up for
political reasons there's a logical
distinction between those two we need to
keep that in mind so that's the story on
Bruce or okay time for some things I
like and then we will get to some things
that I hate so things that I like
there's a series on Netflix I think this
is actually a USA series I guess
called the sinner with Jessica Biel it
is dark I mean like really really dark
it's it's pretty disturbing as well the
basic opener is that Jessica Biel is a
young mother who just randomly stamps a
guy in the beach and we don't know why
she stabbed a guy on the beach she
doesn't remember why she stabbed the guy
on the beach and it's it's really well
done Bill Pullman
gives a very good performance in it as
well so here's a little bit of the
preview it is it is sort of what well
it's sharp objects I guess on HBO I
watched the first few episodes of sharp
objects on HBO is it's so slow that it
is almost unwatchable I in fact it's so
slow that I actually did what I rarely
do I went on Wikipedia read the end of
the plot so I would have be able to skip
the last five episodes of that show but
this is what sharp objects should have
been which is disturbing but but unfold
but a well done sort of murder mystery I
here's a little bit of preview
where did you stab it in his neck had no
interaction with him before today I've
never met him before my life then why
kill him
that's an impulse killing it's emotional
it's worth watching it's pretty
compelling stuff and all the
performances aren't quite good I was it
as this weird thing that seems to be
happening on TV a lot in this in this
series Bill Pullman plays a guy who has
guilt issues and so he likes being
tortured by women sexually we've also
seen that in billions is the thing like
that this is the thing I'm missing
they're like suddenly tons and tons of
people are into this because I can't
think of much many things less sexy than
being and then having pain inflicted
upon me for sexual purposes like that's
just so weird
Hollywood's a weird place now I mean
like it's no it's now in every show it's
like we've tried all of the different
forms of sex and now we have to go into
the fringy stuff so we're just gonna
like have every show feature somebody
getting hit with a toaster in the face
during sex for some reason so it's this
that's a weird just sort of a weird side
point to that show but the show itself
is is well done and and I think worth
the watch certainly it is rated R it's
it's definitely an r-rated thing okay so
other things that I like so Betsy DeVos
the Education Secretary is prepping new
policies on campus sexual misconduct
that would bolster the rights of
students accused of assault harassment
or rape and reduce liability for
institutions of higher education and
encourage schools to provide more
support for victims all of which sounds
good except the feminists don't like it
because they like this vague standard
where if a girl claims that something
bad happened to or of any sort and
anybody fights back against that that
person basically loses their job and
we've actually seen that in place like
Northwestern where Laura Kipnis who's a
professor female professor who's a
feminist at Northwestern University
protested at the standard in
Northwestern where a male professor who
had sex with a female student
apparently voluntarily and then later
she accused him of abuse of power or
something and Kipnis said we met one
actually see you know like the evidence
she was investigated by the University
for that for your than saying that Betsy
DeVos is fighting back against that as
well she should the supposed camp campus
rape epidemic is a bunch of nonsense
there is no campus rape epidemic the
actual Bureau of Justice Department
statistics show that christina hoff
sommers and i talked about this about 1
in 53 women are subjected to actual
sexual assault on campus not one in four
ok that is an order of magnitude
difference it's every rape is horrible
as I've sent a thousand times on the
show rape they should be castrated or
killed it's the worst crime you can
commit against somebody and I may
include murder in that that
not change the actual stats and the fact
that so many of these universities
basically run Stalinist show trials
based on no evidence and then get sued
on the backend right we saw this with
naturist girl I'm ahsoka wits over at
NYU it's really bad stuff so good for
Betsy DeVos the New York Times of course
is very skeptical
they say unlike the Obama administration
guidance documents the Trump
administration's new rules will have the
force of law and content and can go into
force without an act of Congress after a
public comment period last fall mr. Voss
rescinded a 2011 letter prepared by the
Obama administration that outlined the
responsibilities at schools and colleges
that receive federal funding to address
episodes of sexual misconduct victim
rights groups praised the Obama era
guidelines for aggressively holding
schools accountable for complaints of
sexual harassment assault and rape that
they said had been often played down or
ignore critics contended that they too
often trampled the due process rights
for accused students which is absolutely
true if you if you've seen the actual
process on any of these campuses
it's insane we have a criminal standard
for a reason and the idea that you're
going to destroy a student's life based
on a lack of due process seems
fundamentally unamerican
in virtually every way it's it's it's a
none American process good for Betsy
DeVos firm for doing all of this and
again the reason that we take rate so
seriously is because the consequences
for rape should be so serious all of
these fools and the feminist media who
have been claiming that one in four
women on campus is sexually assaulted
and then they conflate actual rape with
a man going in for a kiss with a woman a
woman turns her cheek and glances off
her cheek and that sexual assault now
that's that's complete it's complete
insanity okay time for a quick thing
that I hate
so CNN continues to push news that they
can no longer back up President Trump
has ripped into Carl Bernstein now Carl
Bernstein did a report for the for CNN
suggesting that he knew about the Trump
Tower meeting in advance now do I fully
trust the president that he didn't know
about the Trump Tower June 2016 meeting
in advance between his team and a
Russian Beck lawyer so I really trust
the President on that not really cuz
Trump says the last of ain't true I mean
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna fit about
that but there's been no evidence
presented to actually show that he did
any of that CNN around this story it
turns out the story was basically
provided by Lanny Davis who's Michael
Cohen's lawyer for McLin tonight and
then he retracted it he said well I
didn't actually have knowledge of that
so Trump tweeted out CNN is being torn
apart from within based on their being
caught in a major lie and refusing to
admit the mistake
sloppy Carl Bernstein a man who lives in
the past and thinks like a degenerate
fool
making up story after story is being
laughed at over the country fake news so
this is a classic Trump tweet with all
of the typical hallmarks of an authentic
you got the nickname sloppy Carl
Bernstein which what would he call Steve
Bannon was a sloppy Steve also yeah so
that I do think that you know this is my
only critique of President Trump
nicknames
he needs a broader a broader variety of
nicknames he's actually started applying
signifiers to the same people he should
have a new one for Carl Bernstein like
there are a lot of words in the English
language a little sloppy
stupid right like look let's come up
with some synonyms just just for the
sake of just for the sake of variety he
also says that he thinks that could
generate fool I kind of I will admit I
have a certain fondness for the
president using the term degenerate fool
just because I me what the hell man this
is the world we live in now or were in
the circus might as well enjoy the show
but but Carl Bernstein has indeed
refused to back down from his story but
he won't exactly explain how he knows
the story is true he's sort of betting
that eventually it will come out that
Trump knew about the Trump Tower meeting
because he knows that you'll face no
consequences if that never comes out
because the media want that story to be
true CNN fired back at President Trump
and they tweeted back
make no mistake mr. president CNN does
not lie we report the news and we report
when people in power tell lies
CNN stands by reporting in our reporters
there may be many fools in this story
but Carl Bernstein is not one of
them the this the schoolmarm --is--
nature of CNN communications tweeting
back CNN does not lie we report the news
again it is this insistence that drives
people up a freakin wall if they would
just ignore the president and just let
it sit everybody would understand that
you know it ain't great that the
president always has fake news about
everything he doesn't like it's not that
great that he calls people to generate
fools
he's the President of the United States
you know Abraham Lincoln back in 1863
wasn't going around being like my
political opponents in the press are
degenerate fools and then it's not a
thing to be fair Lincoln was locking
them up but the President of the United
States and now I probably should not be
doing that in the modern media era but
when see and then says stuff like that
then you have Chris Cuomo who actively
is feeding lines to Florida
gubernatorial candidates who are
Democrats it's hard for you to say the
all you do is report and then he was
Carl Bernstein himself double down on
this he responded to Trump's Twitter
attacks he said real Donald Trump I've
spent my life as a journalist bringing
the truth to light through
administration's of both parties no
taunt will diminish my commitment to
that mission which is the essential role
of a Free Press
CNN stands by its story and I stand by
my reporting this is why the president
shouldn't really do this because all it
does is elevate the people who are is
hacking him
it's the Streisand effect for people who
don't follow sort of pop culture stuff
the Streisand effect is there was a
person an environmental photographer who
took a bunch of pictures of the
California coast and wanted to put a
book about it and there was like a map
from above a helicopter shot and
included Barbra Streisand's house nobody
had seen this photo ever
and then Barbra Streisand tried to have
it taken out rescue the guy for like ten
million dollars just a photographer
tried to sue him for like 10 million
dollars and suddenly the photo was
downloaded 1 million times because
people wanted to see what Barbra
Streisand's house look like the
president has the power to make stories
bigger one and he really should be
trying to make them smaller I and and he
has a serious talent for that so that is
not ideal okay final thing that I hate
today so Cosmopolitan magazine in the UK
has has put out a cover of this person
who I don't know who this is but this is
a very obese person test holiday okay so
test holiday I guess is they they call
her a supermodel and the and she's on
the cover
yeah she's got to be at least a hundred
pounds overweight here I mean this is
this is a very obese woman and the idea
here is that this is body positivity
I don't know how we skipped from
anorexia to obesity and missed all the
women in the middle like if we're gonna
do body positivity shouldn't we start
with like a normal-looking a woman and
I'm not saying that you know it's not
normal for certain people to have
genetic conditions to be obese what I'm
saying is that it probably is not a good
idea fat shaming is not the same thing
as health shaming right saying that you
should be healthy I'm not saying that if
this is this woman's healthy weight fine
fair game good for her but I highly
doubt that this is a healthy weight for
any person let alone this person and
treating it as though what the world
truly needs is to change its definition
of sexy to include people who are
dramatically overweight I'm not sure
what the positive impact that is maybe
it makes people feel better but it also
is going to lead to a lot of folks not
losing weight who probably should lose
weight I mean let's be realistic about
this America right now is in the middle
of an obesity epidemic we're not in the
middle of an epidemic of people who are
who are dramatically trying to be
healthier we're in the middle of an
epidemic where people are trying to I
don't care about being healthy and then
they're being told that they should be
fulfilled in their non health if they
were just to put in like Brigitte
fantasy who used to write for Playboy
and I'm friendly with her and she
tweeted something out that I think is
exactly right she basically said like
I'm a normal looking for two year old
woman why am I not on the cover of
Cosmopolitan and why why is it that we
have to go from either rail-thin
supermodels who no woman actually looks
like unless she exercises three hours a
day and eats kale or we have to go with
the 300-pound woman why can't we just go
to like a normal woman in the middle if
you want to glorify what the normal
woman looks like why don't you take like
the average well again when I say normal
I mean like in terms of normal
distribution in the normal distribution
of weight this is on one edge of the
distribution and then the rail then
supermodels on the other edge of the
distribution if you want to focus on
like healthy body image why not focus on
the people in the middle who are
actually living healthy lifestyles why
is that so out of the box but we're a
stupid society where we have to take
every fringe idea and then make it
mainstream and suggest the only reason
it wasn't mainstream before is because
of evil evil evil discrimination okay
time for something uplifting let's do a
song so every week we go through a song
talking about some eternal values here
we are on Psalm 7 this one is a song of
David and it says Lord my god I take
refuge in you save and deliver me from
all who pursue me or they will tear
heart like a lion and ripped me to
pieces with no one to rescue me Lord my
God if I have done this and there is
guilt on my hands if I have repaid my
ally with evil or robbed or without
cause have robbed my foe then let my
enemy pursue and overtake me let him
trample my life to the ground and make
me sleep in the dust one things is kind
of telling about the psalm is how
confident the psalm is so this Psalm is
very confident about the idea that there
is cause and effect and that if you do
something good God will reward you and
if you do something bad God will punish
you well as we see from everyday life
that's clearly not the case there are
plenty of people who do bad things for a
reward and plenty of people who do good
things who suffer but the idea here is
that we have to accept God's justice no
matter how it comes so David was well
aware that he was a sinner I mean this
is one of the different when people say
Donald Trump is like King David yeah
except for the whole repentance part so
you know David was actually rather well
known in the Bible for being a guy who
is penitent in the face of God and what
this psalm isn't is that is David saying
I'm innocent
therefore absolve me it's David saying I
will live with your justice no matter
what it is I believe I'm innocent
but I'm not going to but your justice is
higher than mine and you may have a
different standard for justice than I do
and I think that's why I was talking
with somebody yesterday about my faith
and whether my faith has ever been
shaken and when I said is usually from
what I what I see from other folks faith
is shaken in two particular ways way
number one is they see something bad
happen to someone good right they're
close to somebody and something bad
happens to that person and then they say
how could a good God allow this and I've
never really had such a problem with
that maybe it's because I haven't
suffered enough and you know I hope that
that continues obviously and I can never
blame somebody who's undergone
tremendous suffering and then just
cannot live with the faith that God
knows better than they do it like I
understand the emotional the emotional
draw to that but it is true it's it's a
basic fundamental of religion that God
knows better than you do and so
suffering I've never seen as a real
barrier to faith Christianity in
particular has never seen suffering as
barrier of faith in fact it's it's a
tentpole of faith right Christ literally
is tortured and died for your sins if
you're a Christian and Judaism the idea
is that you know even the greatest
heroes in judaism suffered moses dies
before he's allowed into the promised
land suffering is endemic to the human
condition and that's something that god
knows more about than you do the second
way that people lose faith as they see
members of their
institutions do something bad they look
at other members of the Catholic Church
if you're Catholic or they look at other
members of the Jewish community if
you're Jewish they say there's an
Orthodox Jew who's rude and nasty I
don't like that guy
therefore how could this be a godly
religion if you're judging a faith by
the by the behavior of its adherents I
think that you're making a mistake
because your relationship with God is
between you and God and it's you on a
desert island alone with God because in
the end that's how we all die right into
us on a desert island alone facing down
our maker it is also true that religious
people should understand that
the easiest way to drive other people
away is to act like a bad person and I
think that that's particularly true in
the time when we're talking about
scandals inside the Catholic Church but
as I've said before these scandals exist
in every institution religious and
non-religious it's incumbent on
religious people to go out of their way
not to have guilt on their hands if God
judges them to be guilty that's one
thing but if it's clear that you're
guilty to everybody else then you are
complicit in the in the destruction of
your own religious institutions and you
are complicit in what I would say is is
evil work already we will be back here
tomorrow and we will have all the
breakdowns on the news plus the mailbag
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah all Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018